what up peeps
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for april 13th
2021 there is an awful lot happening in
the world
it sort of feels like the world is on
fire right now and in some cases
it literally is so i will spend the next
half hour of my life
end of your life trying to make some
sense of all of it as always
click that subscribe button on youtube
and tap
the old notification bell and maybe just
maybe you'll get our videos in your
feed uh we've got three stories for you
obviously the big
situation is what's happening in
brooklyn center minnesota
right now we're going to get into that
you know we covered it yesterday and i
really really really tried to give you
an
honest assessment we played the actual
video
of the shooting i tried to give a little
context you know they're saying that the
officer
thought that she was holding a taser not
a gun that is in no way an excuse
because she was an offer
officer for 26 years and obviously at
that point you would think there's
enough training
but you know you can't resist arrest and
he tried to get away and then driveway
it's just like a whole freaking mess and
everybody's going to try to use this
for their own political purposes for
clicks for views
all of those things i'm really really
going to try to keep everybody calm
about this thing uh but it it ain't
gonna get better anytime soon
unfortunately and of course this all
comes with the backdrop
of the george floyd murder trial which
will wrap up you know basically any day
now and we know that no matter what
the outcome is going to be with that
that there were going to be riots this
is the new sort of meme in america
you know no justice no peace but there
is no justice there's no there there
when it comes to justice
except assembling disassembling the
entire state so in effect you say no
justice no peace what you mean is no
peace because we want to just take
out everything so it's going to be a
messy
little while and you know for all the
people awful lot of my
good smart wise liberal friends
who said we just have to get rid of
donald trump because then
we can deal with this woke thing then we
can deal with all of these
problems related to identity politics
and how out of control the progressives
have gone
i think at this point uh your maya culpa
is coming like at some point here little
little apology or
well not even an apology just a little
my bad whoops whoops
misjudged that one because obviously
none of this is getting any better
it's all obviously getting worse and
it's being pushed by our administration
and it's being pushed
by mainstream media or i should say
corporate media there you go michael
malus there's your shout out
and uh yeah it's gonna be messy so the
three stories we're doing we're
obviously touching that one i'll do that
one second
first uh there is a slight warning on
the johnson johnson vaccine
because of blood clots and i want to
just talk about it sort of blue sky
stuff related to that
uh because you know we're keep being
told like we can't do anything until
there's zero
covet infections but now we know that
some of the vaccines are causing some
blood clots it's a very very tiny amount
and again i'm not doing it to be
alarmist but it's like are we allowed to
even talk
about that are we allowed to talk about
it or will that make me a conspiracy
theory or an anti-vaxxer
or something else so uh we're gonna do
that up top then we're gonna do
uh the brooklyn center stuff and then
finally i had to do this story
because this has been sort of a slow
burn for three years
uh but hank azaria who is the i would
say probably
the best voice actor the best voice over
guy that we have
in america maybe in modern times in the
entire world who has done probably
20 30 maybe more we could check how many
voices has he done on the simpsons
uh he is now apologizing for doing the
voice of apu
and over the last couple years you know
there was a documentary made about this
about how offensive that was the
character of up who
and now hank is apologizing and he's not
going to do it anymore
oddly i don't think he's returning any
of the money he does make around 330 000
an episode to work for probably three
hours to do a couple voices uh
that is worth roughly 90 million dollars
didn't say anything about returning any
of the money
but uh he's apologizing because
obviously
that's very racist and i want to talk
about that because the simpsons
at one time it's about 30 years at this
point well what they're in their like
30-second season
they're about i would say 25 years past
their peak but it still
exists as something relevant culturally
and just to watch these guys like
basically crap on the art that they
created is just it's just so terrible
uh okay here we go so let's talk about
uh what's going on with this johnson and
johnson
covid vaccine situation i'm going to
read you two tweets here first from the
fda
today fda and the cdc issued a statement
regarding the johnson and johnson
covid 19 vaccine we are recommending a
pause
in the use of this vaccine out of an
abundance of caution
as of april 12th 6.8
plus million doses of the johnson and
johnson vaccine have been administered
in the u.s the cdc and fda are reviewing
data involving
six reported u.s cases of a rare and
severe type of blood clot
in individuals after receiving the
vaccine right now these adverse events
appear to be
extremely rare and we'll just unpack it
a little bit more with this
piece that was in fox news there have
been six reported cases of a rare and
severe blood clot in over 6.8 million
johnson and johnson coveted vaccine
recipients the type of blood clot is
called
cerebral venice sinus thrombosis
and that it was seen in combination with
low levels of blood platelets all six
cases involved women between the ages of
18 and 48
and symptoms occurred between 6 and 13
days post-vaccination okay so
there's something interesting here first
off let me just be very very clear
we're talking about roughly six people
out of 6.8
plus million that have been vaccinated
so this is not some extraordinary number
and i would be willing to put out there
that anytime you're going to have people
mass vaccinated like this there's going
to be some error there's going to be
some side effects there's probably going
to be
some death so i am not in any way saying
you shouldn't
get the johnson johnson vaccine i have
not
been vaccinated if i am to be vaccinated
i actually think i would take
i would prefer to take the johnson
johnson vaccine which is
sort of an old school vaccine it's
different than the mrna
vaccines that i believe pfizer and
astrozenica
and one or two of the other ones are
putting out there that are sort of newer
better newer medicine that's why it
takes the two shots and and people have
some concerns about that stuff
but the vaccine from johnson johnson is
more the old school is one shot
and you're out a little more like a like
a flu shot
that being said there are obviously some
issues here
and the only reason i wanted to do this
story is not that you should all freak
out about it
or worry about it really but it's like
we should be able to talk about these
things and when we were looking at the
stories this morning
i was looking about eight or ten
different stories and it's like
ah you know if you don't talk about this
if people see the headline and then it's
like ah but nobody's really talking
about it then it starts festering a
little bit more right that whole
sunshine is the best disinfectant thing
so i just want to put that out there but
then
you know there's something else
interesting going on and we're going to
show you some video in just a second
from
jen pasaki at the white house because
they are really going heavy
on this pr campaign to make sure that
every single person is vaccinated now
remember we're about 15 months off
roughly of two weeks to flatten the
curve that's what we were told
now it's every single person has to be
vaccinated
and vaccine passports that for now will
not come from the government but if
you're gonna go
to an event or to a bar or to a
restaurant or basically anywhere
publicly
there's a really good chance that you're
gonna need to show your papers
in essence don't worry i'm not gonna do
my german accent for this one today
um so you know if the government is sort
of giving
guidelines that then private companies
are doing and then we all have to have
this passport well i think there's an
interesting debate
about what type of uh infringement of
our right to privacy that is
and unfortunately as you guys know these
are not the types of debates that you're
going to see anywhere
in mainstream media i would love to talk
to people on both sides of the debate
related to privacy related to vaccines
and all that but
what what's interesting right now is
that
there are an awful lot of people in the
united states that do not want to take
the vaccine and there's an awful lot of
people
all over the world that do not want to
take the vaccine some of them have had
covid so they believe they have the
antibodies some of them are young and
healthy so they don't believe that
they're at risk
some of them don't like the idea of
taking you know one of say four vaccines
that were relatively rushed out to
market
very quickly and the mrna stuff is
pretty new so
everyone's entitled to have their own
fears and
and concerns and all of those things but
the white house is going very heavy
on uh you know pushing the idea that we
should all be vaccinated
and well you can already see who they're
going to blame if people don't get
vaccinated let's take a look
also investing 3 billion dollars to
states and community-based organizations
to strengthen vaccine confidence in the
highest risk and hardest hit
communities and often people think of
that as just black and brown communities
and that is not as you've noted that is
also
conservative communities white
evangelicals it's a range of communities
around the country
what we've found to be most effective is
to work with these local organizations
so
faith-based organizations community
health organizations
civic leaders and others who can really
get this message deeply
in communities we've also had a number
of our um
members of our covid team from dr fauci
and
uh for and dr collins uh participate as
an example
participate in a range of media
interviews you know an example is dr
collins participated in the 700 club
dr nunez smith hosted a faith leaders
roundtable
we're also looking for we've run psas on
the deadliest catch
we're engaged with nascar and country
music tv we're looking for a range of
creative ways to
get directly connected to white
conservative communities we won't always
be the best
messengers but we're still trying to
meet people where they are but also
empower local organizations
man i really don't like her um okay
there's a bunch of stuff there first off
you can see what she did there
we want to go to these communities and
it's not just black and brown she was
really focusing on white evangelical and
the implication is somehow that these
people and it's sort of what she's
really trying to say is
trump supporters sort of don't want this
and what are we going to do we're going
to go to nascar
we're going to be on deadliest catch
they went on the 700 club
so i want to be very very clear right
now i can't
tell you that i like you jan pasake
that's obvious that i don't but if you
are watching this or anyone at the
administration i will gladly have fauci
on
i will gladly have one of the other
doctors that you mentioned and i would
like to talk about this stuff and i will
do it with no notes
and we can air it live um but this this
is very weird i mean this
you can see the way they're framing
things right now it's going to be
these people these white evangelicals
and also the way they
the way they racialize everything and
this
is how the anti-racists become the
racists
the idea of getting vaccinated or not
vaccinated
or the efficacy of the vaccines or any
of that stuff has nothing
to do with race now there are plenty of
people in the black community i hate
saying community related to
the gay community as if it's a monolith
but there are plenty of black people
who have reservations about vaccines
because of things that have been done in
the past
there are plenty of white people for
whatever reason might not want to do
vaccines
and i thought it was sort of that my
body my choice thing wasn't that a
wasn't that a thing that the left was
always telling us my body my choice but
it doesn't
really sound like that's what they mean
anymore now it's
your body our choice right because
you're all gonna have
to take this vaccine again that's not me
sitting here as an
anti-vaxxer although i did watch i am
legend
a couple days ago and it turns out that
the vaccine that they gave everybody
turned everybody into zombies and
it did not work out well for will smith
anyway i just think it's
it's worth noting some of this stuff
that they're they're sort of just
framing things right now like they're
setting us up to be like oh we're going
to need lockdowns again june's going to
roll by and lockdown time and why do we
need it those white evangelicals you
know those christians in the middle of
the country
those nascar christians who watch
deadliest catch
dare watch the reuben report you know
those guys they're the ones so we gotta
lock their we gotta lock em down
lock it down people we're locking it
down all right i think you got my point
guys let's talk about ladder
you know if 2020 has taught us anything
it's that life is unpredictable and no
matter how well prepared we are
there are certain things like pandemics
and lockdowns that you just don't see
coming when you combine that uncertainty
with the rising cost of living
especially here in california
and new expenses like buying a house
which i did last year
it becomes clear that you don't want to
risk leaving your spouse or kids with a
huge financial burden
on that note it makes sense why people
get life insurance especially term
coverage
which is surprisingly affordable why not
pay a bit each month to protect the ones
you love
if you're asking this question choose
ladder ladder makes it impressively fast
and easy to get covered you need just a
few minutes and a phone or a laptop to
apply
ladder smart algorithms work in real
time so you'll find out instantly if
you're approved
no hidden fees cancel any time and since
life insurance costs more as you
age now's the time to cross it off your
list so check out
ladder today to see if you're instantly
approved go to ladder.com
ruben that's l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
reuben reuben lotterylife.comruben now
back to me
all right so the big story obviously
right now is what's happening
in brooklyn center and it's it's
basically on fire and there's been just
absolute
mass destruction you know the meme out
there is no justice no peace
and you know as i said before it's like
well what would justice mean
if you think the entire system is evil
what they mean is
no justice because we're perpetually uh
not going to give you peace there's no
justice there's no there there there is
the justice is an amorphous idea we can
never truly get justice or maybe they
just have to
you know thanos and kill half of us or
or something like that
so what what sparked all this is the
police shooting
of dante wright we showed you the video
yesterday he was pulled over for a
traffic violation
i you know at some level i hate getting
into the minutia of all of these things
because sometimes it doesn't even matter
because it's much more about the
narrative but just so that you guys
watching this know
if you want to watch our video from
yesterday he was pulled over for a
traffic violation it turned out that he
had an outstanding warrant
they tried to arrest him he resisted
arrest he broke free he got into the car
the officer who was a female a 26 year
veteran
she apparently thought she was grabbing
her taser and she's yelling taser taser
taser
but she grabbed her gun that's for up to
other people to figure out if she made a
mistake if she lied
blah blah blah it does sound like she's
very uh upset when she realizes i think
she says i shot him or something to that
effect
uh he drives away he he ended up diving
well dying
in the last i think hour or so it has
now turned out that the police chief who
we read a quote from him yesterday where
he
said that he believed that she had
accidentally pulled out the gun not the
taser
the police chief has now stepped down
and the officer
i believe is on leave or she has stepped
down she's either on leave or she has
stepped down as well
we've got a quote here uh from the
post-millennial and this is now related
to all of the rioting because we're
going to show you a couple videos
in just a moment and you know the
rioting no matter what happens i mean
this is this is i know
i know most of you guys watching this
know this but we need this to be sort of
like a wider idea throughout society
even if even if
something horrific happens even if cops
do something that is
absolutely crystal clear 100
wrong you can't take justice into your
own hands like we all can't be
batman right and we all can't also be
the guy
the other guy the joker right like what
did the joker want to do the joker just
wanted the world to burn
and if you think all these people that
are ransacking all of these stores and
burning down
buildings and attacking people on the
streets and there's a really crazy video
i didn't even want to play it today
of a bunch of people chasing people
screaming they're trying to find white
people to
to beat up and potentially worse if any
of that if you think any of that's going
to bring you justice
make the system better make your
community better you're really misguided
and you're being used by forces that
probably you don't understand probably
that i don't understand actually
probably that very few of us understand
um but you know we've also seen the
corporatization
of all of this where these corporations
keep donating
to all of these causes like blm and then
we do gofundmes to get antifa people out
and
and it never works and that now brings
us to this piece
uh about foot locker uh this is from the
post-millennial back in june of 2020
ceo richard johnson of footlocker penned
a letter committing the company to 200
million dollars over the next five years
to fight
racial injustice this news was perhaps
lost on those who were looting foot
locker stores
on sunday night let me just give you one
other quote then we're going to show you
the video
of that this is from ceo foot locker
richard johnson
we stand resolute in our commitment to
fight racial inequality and injustice
this commitment extends beyond words it
is part of our culture and the way we
operate as an inclusive
and diverse organization we recognize
that black culture plays a pivotal role
in shaping sneaker culture
the foundation of our business at
footlocker inc we believe that we have
an obligation to add our voice and
actions to drive meaningful and lasting
change across our company
and within the communities we serve
today we are announcing that foot locker
is committing 200 million dollars over
the next five years towards enhancing
the lives of our team members
and our customers in the black community
and now let's take video from last night
looters
showing their appreciation to foot
[Music]
locker
[Music]
stop yeah around
okay so do you see what's going on here
and why i want to do this story here's a
company that says we're going to donate
200 million dollars that ain't chump
change to diversity to inclusion stuff
to blm the rest of it
we believe that what what we do in in
selling sneakers
is relevant to the black community and
black culture which it absolutely is
there's no doubt about it by the way i
buy most of my i haven't bought sneakers
in a long time because nobody goes
anywhere anymore
but over the years i bought many many
sneakers tons of basketball shoes
at foot locker okay so i have no problem
with foot locker
i actually like foot locker generally
speaking but here's what foot locker did
as a company they said okay we will put
200 million dollars to this stuff
to this amorphous stuff and we're going
to stop racism and the rest of it which
we all know
is just nonsense it's just sort of this
giant protection racket
except the protection ain't coming so do
you think any of those rioters care
do you think anyone was out there and
was like guys guys
hold up hold up guys not foot locker
not full locker ceo johnson uh donated
200 million dollars let's not go to flag
or go next door to athlete's foot
or what's another shoe store give me
another shoe store athlete's foot that
what
journeys journeys that's pretty white
that's pretty white a lot of skater
shoes in there like let's go to journeys
guys
and take that out no the point is they
don't care
these people don't care they want to
destroy things
and it's it's a very odd match made in
hell where we have
corporations on the same side of the
people that are destroying the
corporations
and then of course we know that you know
all of these companies bring in
diversity inclusion
departments and hr teams who destroy it
from the inside so they get destroyed
from the inside
by focusing on diversity and inclusion
and people's skin color instead of
making the best shoe
and then on the outside they have the
people who they claim they're helping
we're giving you guys 200 million
for that stuff that you really care
about please don't take out our store go
over to journeys
all those skater shoes those skater
punks most of them are white
and nobody cares so it's a real problem
here and we're just going to see more
and more of this
and you know it's also consistent with
sort of what we've seen over the last
couple weeks you know with the with the
georgia
voting law and coca-cola you know
condemning it
and you know mlb condemning it and it's
like you know okay so people in georgia
shouldn't have to have an id
to vote but like if you go to the
coca-cola office guess what if you want
to take a meeting with the ceo for stuff
you're not getting that meeting secondly
yeah they're going to want to see your
id or cnn in atlanta condemning it you
know
you know pushing the idea that the
voting law is racist and it's like yeah
can i get
walk over to cnn headquarters in atlanta
and just
hey uh zucker jeff zucker want a meeting
with you are they gonna let me up the
elevator and
walk me right into his office and
everything else of course not so all of
these people are playing ftse
with something that is in essence gonna
destroy them and
and it is it ain't good it ain't pretty
people
uh all right let's do the third story
today because this is close to my heart
because in many ways the
the prime simpsons of 1989 i remember
i remember watching 1989
sunday nights the simpsons it was
originally part of the tracy allman show
as a tiny little skit
i was 12 13 years old and i remember
thinking it was the funniest freaking
thing ever i could not believe
that something was so funny and then of
course it became the simpsons
tv show i think in 1990 and now it has
been on air
basically forever 31 32 years but you
take
simpsons like seasons one to seasons
eight
and it's comedy perfection that's what
it was and now the simpsons has sort of
become a joke
in a simpsons episode like they've
become sort of the big giant corporate
thing
that they always made fun of over the
years uh but hank azaria who voices
about 20 30 characters on the show did
we get the number on that
uh oh he does 12 reoccurring characters
and more and plenty more one-off voices
so 12 reoccurring characters
and i think he's probably the best
voice-over guy that we have in the
entire country i mean the guy's just
phenomenal
he also played a very very gay guy in
the bird cage and he hasn't apologized
for that remember he was the very gay
chef
in the house with robin williams and the
other gay guy and i don't think he's gay
but he played the gay chef
the house boy was very upsetting to the
gay community
so anyway he is apologizing
for uh playing a pooh not apologizing
for playing the gay guy in the birdcage
but he is apologizing for playing a poo
now apu before i get into this quote
from the daily wire the
apoo is probably the hardest working and
one of the most beloved characters in
the entire simpsons
everyone in the simpsons is deeply
flawed and screwed up
and all of these things i mean think
about any of the characters and by the
way they're almost
all ridiculous stereotypes bumblebee man
right krusty the clown these are all
ridiculous stereotypes okay
um groundskeeper willie okay like have
you seen the show people
um but apu is actually slightly
different
because apu is basically the hardest
working guy in the entire town right
he's busting his butt
at kwik-e-mart in springfield he because
of apu they did
episodes on hinduism and veganism and
they had an
indian wedding um they they did an
entire episode you know the who needs
the kwik-e-mart song one of the best
songs in the history of the simpsons was
an episode where homer was
anti-immigration and then after becoming
friends
with apu he becomes pro-immigration so
this
is what the fabric of america is all
about and done through
comedy and through cartoons it's a
beautiful thing
apu is a beautiful character he's
friends with homer does a lot of stuff
with him they were in a barbershop
quartet
need i go on but now a poo
is being cancelled by hank azaria
himself
now first i'm going to show you a quote
this is from june of 2020 because this
has been a long time coming
so there's here's a piece that they did
in the daily wire the simpsons america's
longest running
animated tv show will stop allowing
white actors to voice
non-white characters in future episodes
so this has been
you know coming for a couple months and
now hank azaria was on a podcast just in
the last week or so and here's what he
said
i was speaking at my son's school i was
talking to the indian kids there because
i wanted to get their input
a 17 year old he's never even seen the
simpsons
but knows what apu means it's
practically a slur at this point
all he knows is that this is how his
people are thought of and represented to
many people in this country
i really do apologize it's important i
apologize for my part in creating that
and participating in that part of me
feels like i need to go to every single
indian person in this country
and personally apologize and sometimes i
do
i mean that is a load of pathetic
woke [ __ ] if i've ever heard it now
hank azari makes 300 000
an episode that's 6.6 million dollars a
year
to do 12 voices including up who he's
worth roughly 90 million dollars and by
the way i don't think hank azaria
is a bad guy i think i actually met him
once at a at some hollywood party years
ago for two
seconds i don't think he's a bad guy but
he's he's playing
footsie with the thing that will destroy
him and now he has to bow forever and
you all know
how this script goes you're supposed to
stand up to it like gina carano
not bow to it like this but you know
hank if you're watching
and you're you know apologizing to all
the indian
people i know i i have at least two good
friends who are indian and i know plenty
of other indian people
you want to share some of that dough
with them because an apology is one
thing
but we all know this is really an
extortion racket which is why the head
of
blm is buying five million dollars worth
of houses as we covered yesterday
so how about if you've got roughly 90
million bucks i mean
i don't know i don't know how many how
many indian people do we have in america
i mean let's do some math here and
figure out how much money
you could give to each indian person for
the amount of racism
that you've created even though apu is a
wonderful character
who has done all of those things so uh
uh there are 2.7 million
indians in the united states you've got
90 million bucks
so if we just divide that you know we
say 2.7 we'll say it's three
i mean you can give some money to these
people that's that's that's pretty good
man
you know like that we should be doing it
oh hank
hank if you're watching don't apologize
and you guys
never apologize because it means nothing
it means absolutely nothing you know i i
did a story
a couple years ago before we were doing
this direct-to-camera show but we
covered it
in an interview format about how seth
macfarlane who created family guy that
they suddenly announced after years
they're not going to do gay jokes
anymore now i don't watch
the simpsons anymore and i don't watch
family guy anymore i
don't even have cable so i don't even
know how you would watch those things
and i don't think young people care
about these things which is why
um panca zaria is telling you that his
son's 17 year old friend doesn't even
watch the simpsons
but you know seth macfarlane basically
said we're not going to do gay jokes
anymore it's like you made
a [ __ ] ton of money i'm sure seth
mcfarland is worth more than 100 million
dollars
you made fun of gay people you made fun
of gay people with aids
you made fun of all of these you made
fun of black people you made fun of jews
you made fun of christians you made fun
of muslims you did all this stuff and by
the way
that makes us all american but when we
pick
groups that we don't make fun of or
things that we don't draw
or ideas that we don't talk about
because certain people might get upset
then we actually compartmentalize
ourselves
and do something very reverse the
american dream and and in many ways guys
that is what is up for debate right now
is the american dream still something
worth saving or
should we all become fearful
self-canceling
little weasel freaks
i think you know which side of that i'm
on uh and i also know what side of it my
guest this week nick
gillespie nick gillespie nick gullespie
i guess in some ways
you might uh you keep calling him
gillespie that's why i said it uh
nick gillespie from reason magazine part
one of my interview with him who's
completely against cancel culture and he
was the guy
sitting next to that ridiculous former
senator heidi heitkamp
as she called gina carano racist and a
nazi and a white supremacist
on real time with bill maher so we dive
into that and much more you can get part
one on youtube right now the full
episode is up ad free as always at
reubenreport.locals.com and we are going
to do a friday panel this week on race
and policing because
obviously that issue is not going on uh
well it ain't going anywhere anytime
soon unfortunately
uh brandon brandon tatum my friend and
and former guest several time guest
will be on the show mike the cop who's
big on the youtube and elijah shaffer
who i've had on
uh from the blaze will all be on and
we'll unpack what's happening
in minneapolis this week how that sort
of stands to
to set the tone for everything that's
going on across the country right now
and we'll see if we can figure out some
ways around it
anyway i feel uh i feel this was a solid
program today we did a little bit of
everything
i know that i will look back on it
fondly i hope you will too
have a great day everybody we'll see you
tomorrow